in 1957 the soviet union launched
sputnik 1. it was the first satellite in
earth's orbit
or was it
for over 100 years an unidentified
object orbiting the earth has been seen
heard and photographed by people all
around the world this object became
known as the black knight satellite
the signals from the black knight
satellite have been decoded
and if the translation is correct it's
been watching us for 13 000 years
let's find out why
[Music]
at his lab in colorado springs nikola
tesla built a large tower to study
atmospheric electricity and wireless
power but one evening in 1899 tesla got
a surprise his tower started receiving a
transmission a transmission that tesla
believed to be artificial his antenna
was receiving numbers at a regular
interval at first tesla thought it was a
signal coming from high in the
atmosphere it turned out the signal was
coming from higher than that it was
coming from space
tesla believed that this was evidence of
life on another planet he's quoted in a
local newspaper as saying i believe
numbers are being used for communication
because numbers are universal the
scientific community certainly
acknowledged tesla's genius but they
also thought of him as a bit of a mad
scientist but a few years later
guillermo marconi inventor of the
wireless radio also intercepted those
same signals then jorgen halls a
norwegian radio engineer noticed
transmissions being sent on a certain
wavelength were being sent back a few
seconds later now radio echoes
themselves are not unusual radio waves
especially shortwave can bounce between
the ground and stratosphere several
times this is called propagation but
typical radio echoes usually occur
one-seventh of a second after the
original transmission consistently these
echoes were happening at different
intervals up to 15 seconds after the
transmission and weren't consistent with
signals that bounce around the earth
these signals are now known as long
delayed echoes or ldes and for years
after their discovery shortwave and ham
radio operators have observed ldes but
how and why they occur remains a mystery
or does it on may 14 1954 two american
newspapers reported a story that might
explain these radio echoes the story got
scientists very excited it also caused
the pentagon to panic
[Music]
on may 14 1954 three years before
sputnik became the first satellite in
orbit a strange news story appeared the
report claimed that according to an
expert one or two artificial satellites
are circling the earth the expert in
question was marine corps major donald
kehoe major kehoe was a naval aviator
who later became a ufo researcher and
founded the national investigations
committee on aerial phenomena or nycap
he claimed that u.s government
scientists working out of white sands
new mexico had found one or two
artificial satellites and we're trying
to track them a few weeks later we got
some more details it was reported that
two satellites had been found at 400
miles and 600 miles above the earth
these satellites were emitting a strange
radio signal at periodic intervals much
like tesla discovered years earlier dr
lincoln lapaz an astronomer out of the
university of new mexico was in charge
of a team trying to locate and id the
objects the pentagon was upset that this
information leaked but when you receive
broadcast from a satellite before
satellites are invented it's hard to
keep that a secret a few weeks after
that nasa detected signals from what it
called an unknown orbiting object
and those signals were confirmed by
astronomers in france and elsewhere the
american military was concerned these
were russian spy satellites launched in
secret they weren't in 1957 a researcher
for the venezuelan government was
observing sputnik 2 as it passed over
caracas he noticed a mysterious object
at first he thought it was sputnik but
it couldn't be sputnik moves in
pro-grade orbit meaning from west to
east along with the rotation of the
earth
the object he saw was moving in
retrograde orbit moving east to west
opposite the rotation of the earth so
well this technology didn't exist
throughout the late 1950s there were
multiple observations of what was called
a dark satellite and by 1960 the defense
department finally acknowledged it on
february 11 1960 the new york times ran
an article which said washington
february 10 an unidentified silent
satellite has been discovered circling
the earth in a near polar orbit by
united states tracking stations the
defense department said today the
identity and origin of the mystery
satellite which has been dubbed the dark
satellite are not known despite nearly
two weeks of tracking this report
renewed interest in the satellite and
astronomers around the world reported
seeing it and what was strange about it
was it didn't have a regular schedule it
appears some nights but not others they
didn't know when to watch for it now
this was the height of the cold war and
the pentagon was absolutely terrified
that this was some kind of new russian
spy satellite that could appear and
disappear at any time that year time
magazine even wrote about the black
knight satellite and how the navy was
trying to track it and grumman aircraft
a military contractor was tasked with
tracking and photographing the satellite
which they did in august 1960 but that
report and those photographs have never
been released in may 1961 the
smithsonian observatory at harvard
spotted the object they even reported
this in the press with a statement the
satellite was first spotted over florida
an unsuspecting unpredicted bright
satellite stations around the world have
been asked to help drackett and this is
exactly what happened from his paris lab
jacques valet observed tracked and even
filmed the black knight satellite the
first thing that stood out was that it
was in polar orbit now there were no
earth-based satellites in polar orbit
yet what's interesting about this is
satellites in polar orbit are very well
positioned to observe all points of the
earth's surface when a country wants to
see everything they choose polar another
fact about the object that stood out it
was huge about the size of an oil truck
and weighed about 15 tons there was no
rocket on earth that had the ability to
launch something this size now valet and
his team were thrilled at the discovery
he compiled all the research the photos
the film put them in a large file and
delivered it to a supervisor
the materials were immediately
confiscated the photos were destroyed
and the film was erased the official
reason for destroying the film was that
the observatory was embarrassed that it
couldn't identify the object now that's
a bunch of ps i agree
so did valet by the way valet is still
alive and this is something that bothers
him to this day and he wasn't a ufo guy
before spotting the black knight
satellite but he became one after he's
written 15 books and tons of papers
challenging mainstream science and
supporting the existence of ufos this
guy sounds all right for a frenchman it
does sound pretty cool
up until now the only sighting of the
black knight satellite came from
astronomers and observatories on the
ground to really prove the existence of
the black knight we need an eyewitness
to go to orbit and see it with their own
eyes and just 18 months later that's
exactly what happened
gordon cooper was the stereotypical
1960s american astronaut short hair fast
car cocky attitude he learned to fly
when he was just a child and then he
became a fighter pilot a test pilot and
one of the first astronauts in 1963 he
piloted mercury 9 which was the longest
american space mission ever at that time
and gordon cooper was like somebody out
of a movie when his landing module
experienced total systems failure he did
what a movie hero would do he switched
everything off and brought his ship down
manually he splashed down safely just
four miles off target and this
experience didn't scare him at all he
kept going to space and kept breaking
endurance records here's how tough
cooper was to this day he's the only
person to ever fall asleep during
liftoff he fell asleep while his rocket
was launching yep
i guess he'd done it so many times he
was bored and decided and i'll just take
a nap now we all know the names neil
armstrong and alan shepard but those
astronauts stood on the shoulders of men
like colonel gordon cooper anyway during
mercury 9 cooper reported seeing a green
glowing object ahead of his module his
ground crew also confirmed this and a
tracking station saw it moving east to
west
prograde nbc news immediately picked up
the story but when cooper got back from
the mission the press was not allowed to
ask about the sighting the official
explanation was there was an electronic
malfunction on cooper's craft this
caused high levels of carbon dioxide
which induced hallucinations
yep the guy who's so cool under pressure
that he falls asleep during takeoff was
seeing things while he was at nasa and
active military gordon cooper felt
duty-bound to follow orders about what
he saw and denied the sighting
but after he retired
that's a different story cooper claimed
that while he was a test pilot at
edwards air force base he saw strange
saucer-shaped craft and the saucers made
no sound as they landed on retractable
gear and cooper said that even the most
fearless test pilots were shaken by the
things they saw at edwards and right up
until his death cooper claimed that the
u.s government was definitely covering
up information about ufos
and you said you saw literally hundreds
of unidentifiable flying objects yes
they were flying quite high how high we
couldn't tell because we couldn't get
anywhere near their altitude
but they were either very large craft
way up or
smaller crafts still well above what we
can get to he can recall hundreds of
reports made by fellow pilots that were
confirmed by radar cooper even testified
before the united nations about this now
sightings of the black knight satellite
piled up over the years it became
increasingly difficult to deny that
something was up there so the bigger
questions are what is it
why is it here and what does it want we
would get that answer in 1973.
duncan london a researcher from scotland
went back and analyzed all the lde data
compiled from the norwegian scientists
london found a pattern and in that
pattern a message
and in that message
a map
[Music]
in a 1973 article in spaceflight
magazine duncan london said he had
identified a hidden radio message sent
by the black knight satellite london had
gone back to the lde data and noticed
variations that might indicate a code so
he put the data on a graph on one axis
was the time delay between echoes on the
other axis the position of each echo in
the sequence and plotting these points
didn't create any recognizable pattern
so london reversed the axes the result a
collection of dots that appeared to be a
sky map specifically the constellation
botus
what it looks like
the only star in the constellation that
was out of place was epsilon boates
london felt this could indicate the
black knight satellite's origin now he
admitted this evidence was shaky so he
found more radio echoes reported by
french astronomers in 1929
those graphs confirmed it was the same
constellation there was one big problem
though arcturus the brightest star in
the constellation was slightly
off-center london couldn't explain this
so he changed his thinking maybe the
satellite didn't arrive here recently
maybe it was showing a star map from a
time in the past okay this is the part
where i ask you what the hell you
talking about okay so the earth rotates
on its axis right yeah well over time
gravity causes this axis to wobble like
a top but it's consistent and
predictable the orientation of the
earth's axis makes a full cycle every 26
000 years so over long time spans the
stars in the sky look slightly different
in this rotation of the sky map is
called axial procession what does this
have to do with the black nightmare well
arcturus was slightly out of place for
1973 but when london adjusted the map
further back in time accounting for
axial procession the stars lined up the
black knight satellite wasn't a new
arrival according to the map it's been
here for thirteen thousand years
london said that the diagrams were so
clear that they could be interpreted as
a message in standard english the black
knight message says our home is epsilon
which is a double star we live on the
sixth planet of seven coming from the
sun which is the larger of the two our
sixth planet has one moon our fourth
planet has three our first and third
planets each have one our probe is in
the position of arcturus known in our
maps
what's going on
well that's a first even though these
reports were in the new york times time
magazine and other mainstream news
outlets nobody at least officially took
the subject of ufos or the black knight
satellite seriously but in 1998
everything would change when space
shuttle endeavour took this photo
on december 4th 1998 the space shuttle
endeavour embarked on mission sts-88 the
first shuttle mission to the
international space station the primary
purpose of this mission was to deliver
and install a piece of equipment called
the unity node unity connects the
russian and american segments together
where the crew can share meals and hang
out but that wasn't the most notable
event of the mission on december 11th a
series of photos were taken and released
by nasa and they show what appears to be
some type of craft in orbit around the
earth
and it seems that after a hundred years
of speculation we finally have proof of
the mysterious black knight satellite
that leaves the question why is it here
one theory is that it's an alien probe
sent to monitor our species and our
progress now this would make sense that
if there is an advanced intelligent
civilization somewhere in the galaxy
they would send probes to every star
that could possibly support life and
when we reach this level of technology i
have no doubt that we'll do the same
thing
and if the black knight satellite is an
alien probe could the radio signals be
reporting back to its home ship or its
home planet or could the signals be for
us could they be sending us a map as a
sort of interstellar handshake or maybe
it's not an alien probe at all but a
piece of technology left by our
ancestors thousands or millions of years
ago there are multiple ancient texts
that describe a dark object orbiting the
earth some call it a dark arc that was
put there thousands of years ago and
that arc contains dna information of
human-like species from long ago aware
that some catastrophe was going to doom
the civilization they put their dna
somewhere safe a place that doesn't care
about ice ages sea levels or even
nuclear war what safer place than in
orbit around the earth and by placing
the ark in orbit you not only ensure the
safety of its contents you ensure that
the only way to become aware of it is by
reaching a certain level of technology
now we have the ability to visit the
black knight satellite we could send a
craft into its orbit right now and try
to discover its secrets or we could
bring it back to earth and share its
secrets with the rest of the world why
haven't we done this
who knows maybe the reason the black
knight satellite is kept secret from the
world is because someone has already
visited and maybe even opened it and
maybe they didn't like what they found
[Music]
the black knight satellite is a
fascinating story the modern version of
the legend is a combination of a few
stories rolled into one so let's unravel
the truth throw away what's false and
see what's left so tesla and marconi did
hear radio pulses but they weren't
aliens they were pulsars and pulsars
weren't discovered officially until 1968
so they would have definitely sounded
like an intelligent broadcast to tesla
aliens could be using pulsars to
communicate they could be that would be
an efficient way to do it still they
weren't coming from the black knight now
the lds or long-delayed radio echoes are
harder to explain
they're actually still a mystery
but most scientists think it's something
in the atmosphere that's causing it
another theory is that the signals are
reflecting off plasma clouds from the
sun and a fun theory is that the signals
are being reflected back from the moon
whatever's causing it we still don't
know now duncan london's translation of
the lds into star maps
it doesn't hold up the scrutiny he later
walked the claims back saying there
wasn't scientific evidence he was just
deducing what he thought the signals
could mean but since then he's revised
his opinion once again and thinks
epsilon bowotis is special booties
now the pictures from nasa are amazing
the official explanation is that during
a spacewalk an astronaut was installing
a thermal cover the cover got away from
him and ended up floating away the
pictures were taken to document this a
space blanket that's what they're going
with well that's the official
explanation and in some of the photos it
does look like a flat shiny object but
in other photos
it looks pretty solid all right let's
assume that the earliest evidence the
radio signals and the latest evidence
the photos are debunked
let's just assume it still the evidence
in between
it's interesting for example there was a
newspaper report of an object spotted in
1960. the us government said this was
actually the discoverer 5 capsule that
got off course
fine
why was it moving in retrograde when
satellites didn't do that the government
said that it malfunctioned and the
thrusters sent it in the wrong direction
okay if that's true and it was the
discoverer 5 which was entered into the
database in 1960
how does that explain that even though
the news report was from 1960 it was
actually referring to a sighting earlier
in 1959
well the government said that someone
accidentally entered the wrong date into
the system alpha crying out loud you
believe this hey i'm i'm just telling
you what happened what makes the story
even more suspicious is that all of this
was a lie anyway the military was using
discoverer as a cover story for the
corona project a spy satellite program
it kept that information classified for
years so let's assume that sighting is
debunked what about all the other
evidence
sightings from around the world
confirmed by governments and private
citizens why were photographs and film
mysteriously destroyed why are there
astronauts claiming there is an active
cover-up there are a lot of questions
left unanswered now do i think tesla
heard the black knight satellite no
do i think the nasa photos are the black
knight satellite no do i believe
eyewitness reports from astronauts and
astronomers who put their reputations in
jeopardy by speaking out
yes i do there is clearly more to the
story that we're not being told and
because you're watching this right now
i know you care about the truth
so you have to keep asking questions you
have to keep the pressure on and those
in power will try to dismiss you they
will not take you seriously but that too
is a lie those in power take you very
seriously they can silence one
astronomer and they can silence one
astronaut but they can't silence all of
us you could feel the dominoes about to
fall i feel it too it's going to take
courage for someone to push that first
domino but once it finally falls they
all fall and when that happens there's
no turning back
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor like
comment and share this video it really
helps out a small channel and if you're
new here and enjoy this type of content
i hope we earned your subscription but
if not it just means we have more work
to do thanks to our generous patrons who
make this channel possible i couldn't do
this without you thank you patrons guppy
needs a new pair of shoes
haha men brother until next time be safe
be kind and know that you are
appreciated
[Music]